[Music]
jt is on the line to kick off this hour
and st louis jt welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can can i help
okay uh let me start by saying i'm i'm
getting ready to do something i don't
want to do but i'm also going off for
the mantra uh happy wife
happy life oh boy oh that's a setup
boy oh boy jt that's one of the better
setups i've ever heard i can't wait to
hear what this thing is you're about to
do because your wife is making you
go jt
um
we are debt-free we paid off our
mortgage and all our bills baby step
seven
yes wow way to go man
thank you thank you we just haven't made
our way east to do the uh debt crew
streams but um i'm dying to do it uh so
i promised my wife a car
or a jeep she found one
um you know they're very hard to find
apparently she found the one color that
is like you could never find so we've
got about 37 000 in savings which um
that is our emergency fund but also our
car fund uh-oh um apparently uh jeep's
coming in in two weeks i got a pretty
good price but we're gonna be about
fifteen thousand dollars short
on hold on hold on hold on i got to get
some details i don't want to interrupt
this momentum here
37 000 and that's and you're going to be
15 short so you're telling me 52 000 for
this jeep that only comes in this one
color and leaves you with zero dollars
well i still want to keep some money in
the emergency fund so
the price is 41 000. oh okay it's only
slightly slightly better than what i
described exactly what's the color of
the jeep i gotta know
okay it's uh it's a word i've never
heard before called snozberry oh geez
you're joking someone made that how do
you spell that is this a prank call
apparently it's a dark red
i'm looking it up okay it's a dark red
jeep that's the same
berry james this is from willy wonka in
the chocolate factory yes
okay
this is a thing though that jeep is
marketing and it's got jt's wife on the
hook man all right
all right so what's the problem you're
about ready to do you said i'm about
ready to do something bad i think that's
i think we all know what it is
we've went through our bank and i can
get a loan
the maximum would be about five months
and they're fine with that the minimum i
would have to take out is ten thousand
and we literally save anywhere between
seven and eight thousand per month
so i we can really pay this off in three
to four months max if you can pay it off
in three to four months and you can save
it up in three to four months
i agree but
the car should be coming in in about two
weeks well wait a second is it the only
what's the name of it a snozzle
is it the only snozberry jeep in the
entire united states sentence on the
show today i never thought i'd say that
you have tried apparently we've tried
no no no
[Music]
we haven't tried sounds like mama has
tried and you're just being made you're
being made aware of all of this is this
breaking news to you jt
uh as of four days ago yes
i i thought i heard that when you said
it's on the way did she already commit
to this
no uh we did put a deposit down of 500
they wanted 2 000. i said no way 500 is
it refundable
uh no
well here's the deal jt you paid a 500
stupid tax
and we're not getting that car i'm gonna
research george please straighten jt i'm
gonna research schnozberry jeeps right
now please do i don't believe it's the
only one in the united states here's the
thing jt number one your emergency fund
and your car fund need to be separate
yes because as you can see this is what
happens when you combine them it becomes
well it's a squishy fun for the car
slash emerge this is not an emergency
so separate this out three to six months
of expenses what does that look like for
you
uh six months would be right around
seven thousand dollars
seven thousand yeah a month
no no no total you're saying six months
of expenses for you guys is seven
thousand dollars total
yes
we have no car payments we have no debt
whatsoever even just insurance premiums
sinking funds i mean you name it it's
got to be more than that food gas
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just talking those
no so let's uh
sell probably about 25 000.
okay that's a very different number than
seven okay so let's say 25 000 is our
magic emergency fund number that means
we have 12 000 to put towards the car
okay
yes this is reality so 12 000 and we
need 41 to get this cheap
so what does that tell you we are short
about 29 000 right
correct so the question becomes how
quickly can we save up 29 000
and then we go jeep shopping
you told me you could save six seven
thousand a month
yes
okay so then we're doing some more math
here and going okay in about four months
or less
we can have this jeep and you can it's
going to take that much time to see it
seems like to order another one
well that's what i'm hoping is that
right now it's due to be in in two to
three weeks but they said that it could
be two two to three months
so with that into
your wife has car fever and she needs to
freaking chill man
here's the only question i have jt
you guys walk the baby steps out how
long you been following dave ramsey and
ramsey solutions i'm just curious
three years three years was she all in
on this process
she was eighty percent
okay all right and so now all of a
sudden she's like well we can wiggle so
did you let me ask you this when you
called us
by the way it's a good thing dave's not
in today no the call wouldn't have
lasted this long
what did you think we were going to say
um i just
because it's such a short loan and we've
got very stable jobs and we make about
240 a year i knew you wouldn't say yes
how about this i'll give you a dave
quote since he's not here oh i like it
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good which you
did
you did devise a plan and follow it and
here's the deal you guys make enough
money to where you're gonna just have to
all right so
uh
here's what i would do if i were you jt
i'm co-hosting today so george is the
money expert but i'm just gonna lay it
out there's a guy who's been married 24
years this is a marriage conversation
yeah this is not you're you're you're
posing this as a
as a
automobile conversation you got to say
hey no we make enough money to save up
there'll be another snozberry jeep we
can order this is a benjamin button
situation she's reverting back to
childlike form okay
at all we cannot let this happen jt the
snozzberry can wait by the way what is
the first and last time i'll ever say
that i do want to say jt thank you for
the question because i never even knew
what snozzberry is i'm looking up a suit
right now it's literally just maroon
it's a maroon jeep who cares there's
more maroon jeeps out there in the world
snozzberry
oh i'm exhausted